e
Claudia Allora
Primero
ostaa secondo postura clinostatica
poa clinostatica
cam Sagrado
Sì
sagr postura
soloc perfetto maess
pun facev controll disorganizzazione
neurologica Sì E facevo cammino e Ponci
Ponci casca pesi e volta Cama sempre
Ponci qualche CIB
cammino una perché se è negativo è
negativo su cammino è sempre
buono
cos
F imposs se teste cam Alter comeo gente
continua Avia o
eserci cam f f alterato esercizio
poss di 21 no F in casa perché essendo
un problema Endo un
problema non
posso pazien con camminio io fa consulta
camminio e m in casa minimo vinci un
giro minimo vin un giro
perché
perae da problema Problema
important significa quando um problema
no regist
do é na segunda parte da
posturologia sim Porque Ele falou que
podia Fazer um reset também né que a
Pessoa faz O exerci que Ela Fez Agora
SIM quando Tem um
seja de um lado Ou do Outro seja na
Perna Ou no brao V Fazer o
exerc Fazer o exerci Mas se eu quiser
Fazer no mesmo dia Eu posso Fazer Como
como mostrou ontem né é Isso sempre faz
Ass SIM a d um reset na hora Eu posso
continuar pode continuar pode continuar
po continuar o o de d um tempo desab um
tempo de du horas horas du 3 horas SIM D
tempo
S
diagn é Isso a precam falar disso ontem
Porque dava Uma janela de 2 horas que
podia continuar o teste é o pror di Tem
problema depois depois e quanto tempo
faz o exerc para Fazer o reset de 2
horas 5 minutos 5 minutos 7 minutos se
for mais velha mais tempo mais mais
tempo bom mais jovem crianca um minuto
lembra Mas é andando né Mas Mas n Esse
exerc de Fazer o o movimento é Eu mesmo
é Eu mesmo eu mesmo
Ah
perfet Temp
ma
repan minut minuto minuto e scusa Mao é
minuto usa buon senso usa su Tem Como B
Sens falando
exero
minimo minimo un minuto sai che fai un
minuto fai se
testi testi se risolv qu
rolv min minimo un minuto un
[Musica]
V minut 10 minut importan
quando eser Nuo cam Cioè non
fidanza esercizio tut bene No non è SIM
esercizi
T esercizio
conio risol problem per poi V con non
Consi non è perché Consi perché mai
Mao Cioè se un vel per
[Musica]
esempio un minuto 2 minutos che non è
aage È un tempo di patologia di
patologia Iso è important
oko risolve Ah all la nostra una buona
indica Pens
ehess nono
tempo
poi Cont per esempio una cheda acidente
eh a mulher a mulher
bateu dele sei Como bateu
Bav Tapa
tapaa fale Eu tenho Uma dvida aqui Em
Rela à consulta Ou o paciente chegou no
Meu Consult e Eu vou Comear a avaliar
Ele Eu comecei com o teste do caminho
fiz o teste do caminho Deu alterado Mas
comecou a tirar foto l primeira co Tudo
Bem Mas vamos l teste de caminho é
Porque enrosca aqui
né ent Deu teste do caminho Deu errado
Deu alterado a Eu vou Fazer l o exerc e
vou explicar para Ele A O que que Eu FAO
com Esse paciente Eu Falo Agora pode ir
embora e volta daqu continua col Ass Ah
Ou Eu vou continuar Mas du horas depois
é Isso que Eu entendi ainda Eu T Nessa
confus entendi
escuta chega para Fazer Uma consulta de
dia
mand
quess Cont disorgan neurologica per se F
dis
neurologica
Alter minut continuo
teste se
certo Aho
ben non
Conso Bu
problema
mand in
casa un
tempo tempo
perch Def un tempo vin un Gir già
intendi
minimo a paga
aaba acababa du ma quando oggi a magn
una terza una quarta una quinta mai fai
su esercizio mai su eserci non è mai
eserci ma C cibo è un trattamento
trattamento è un
trattamento
punto de [ __ ] Sem un trattamento
dep dep un
tempo
manda esercizio quando quando vo le
voltate poi su un mese [ __ ] Certo che di
nuovo da capo la Consulta de controlle e
non m problema tu camminio son un
problema per manese allora qual è
problema se sta una causa che
eh una ca sì switching na causa do uma
uma causa para essa
eh buc casa
maol se un ciclista St che
volta Oh amico mio mio amico bicicletta
Ma cammina poco cmin po si c una cha
Vabbè tratt
cheda
e tutto bene ma
sta sempre una Cusa per pazien perg o
sof cammino St sempre buscare no svolt
con
certezza si va svoltare
Baglio ma fig perché facendo la Consulta
chinesiologia Busca la C Busca Sempre se
pusc
problema todos entenderam uhum SIM
professor a foto é antes de teste do
caminho e e da Ponte a foto fot é Prim
primeiro tipo documenta que Vai ter do
paciente
chegou a Ele vem com R panorama Isso
important secreta
solicita vamos
adiante vamos Adi
all per
SC
allora un
poco interior Inter interior internas
vamos fechar as pernas perfeita e Tem
Nada n a media Tem Nada quando Tem pode
ser o qu n é Isso al S Isso A digamos
que Eu encontrei Uma simetria a uhum é
Eu anoto essa informa no ponturi Eu
posso chegar a alguma conclus nenhuma
Isso
melor aunica conclus que pode chegar é
que se se no caso quea poro [ __ ] SIM
m
postur se Fim Sì e non SAP che è quasi
impossibile una
per
e
Cig a FITA mrica
umbigo
perché per scusa
laà Toro
Toro torso
Ass mais Ca Long SIM eh stato Sì poi non
important per stato busc consulta
perato
sapca enton qu torso enton problema
torsional dessa sabemos tirou alguma
conclus incompleta mas tirou
quad
Sì una Integra Perna quad e
fotos
Fi sì claro Claro già sai non Sapi perch
ma Sapi comea è sì
Eh
certo
S também po Iso
hum na mesma linha da Basso doho para
ver se na mesma l mesma
l mesma l mesma l e
se bom [ __ ]
bom todos sabem
identificar Tem que veras Por favor Eu
onso
Superior olha aqui falso calma
a MMA
Altura
torto
torto pode até Fazer um pegar Uma regu
alum SIM sa sa que para quem
comea é bom comprar Uma FITA méa
SIM ol
Bigo
Sì meglio Bigo punto basso Bigo
l'anza referen Sì a
chi una differenza meglio ctim è
fisiologica non è patologica meglio
ctim 6 mm è fisiologica a te 6 m Sì Dipi
eh non
è la differenza c e me cm No è verdadero
che noi stiamo su una etinomia una
differenza di comprimento da Sper io vio
su quattro caso la mia su quattro
deoma Fi un caso col omici caso di
displasia cadera non
libro e è sempre una Una dismetria ossia
un Quadrio tsion sempre Iso sì la prova
è che F metrica
mostra
complimento
confianza
tranquillo
disale Bui SAP cheeta perché nun
paziente Mao Sen sa cheeta Sì
impossibile Fis Fis
fiscia gamb quanto
ctim per esempio 2
C duei Eh
sì
secondo Eh sei impur muta te che scega
fin movimento Ess simmetrica e braa
memo un calcolo per esempio
0 90
eh 90 gr eh c 9
85 stamo osserva as simmetria se
simmetria asimmetrico per esempio per la
nostra è significativo una dotazione
Cipo
eho se lado blocato significato
se
associao frag é
important observar essa
situo mais importante a simetria range
né
movimento
SIM se tiver assimétrico Qual é A anota
que Vai Fazer é S que simétrico Ou maisa
coisa Vai vai Es Por exemplo esquerda
45° dira
90 Porque Esse é é é dado dado é um dado
que Tem que
mudar da consulta D para chegar com Uma
conclus dessa simetria T Tor também do
quadril Tor de
geral bom Vai Conus pena Eu T
perguntando Isso Porque Assim e Eh e Eu
quero colocar o o o carro na frente Dos
Bois é O que Eu T querendo dizer é O que
que Eu posso colocar No prontu para nos
mdosicilia1946
dados SIM é S Isso S para registro né
para registro para registro Registro S
Isso queria goha muito que Vai a Fazer
um diagnostica Compa Porque faz primos
teste no Final consulta Mas é é Eu acho
que Eu T me Express mal é que Eu quero
Fazer o diagnstico Eu S quero tirar
oximo deaes disso Para registrar No
prono S
que escr O que olhando bom bom 45 90 Ou
que 45 45 20 20 SIM Esse dado Vai
comparar depois
do7 Fazer juzo né S Isso que pode Fazer
Porque Agora é Isso que Vai Fazer
entendeu ver O grau que Ela e anotar vai
anotar No prontu Eu sei O que significa
Isso ainda S vou anotar Eu também sei O
que significa
legamentoso Meu
deado
legamento
mais rigido
se
asimmetria Iso Iso
Isa AG
quad
Allora martello martello
[Musica]
martello
Attenzione attenzione
stabiliz
ausch 0
90 70
è
camento
Perello po
ma è sempre sempre 70 70
eh E scrive 70 70 eh
ta la segi da sei gamba sempre retta
retta
allora a
teamo te A te chi Eh non 90 35 eh 80 80
80 0
80 né 8 no m b
8o melor che a maioria da Sì sì è
verto sto buscando per esempio pera è un
dato che un poco in contrasto no con
cheina torsion ma buscando una simmetria
Sì
dioica non sai come collocarsi ancora
non sai in
perché che sienza si teme se una duen
soo da parte superior curpo per esempio
Sì no non saamo però è sidato un poco
Diciamo un poco in contrasto Element in
contrasto contrasto un po' sud cioè non
è non
è D autosta tinha Uma assimetria do da
cristela a Agora aqui deitado assumiu
assimetria Em contraste apou com carico
postur S que épico do que Tem do
ligamentos
Sado notiz
Mas Agora que falta Rota passa capo cabe
aabe capo Foi aabe é do C
cabea
mais seguindo
aqui nono
non St
pero un po blato
eh
Levant
Eh quanto
è 45 50 50 Schera AG
Gir
menus 40 40 ma non è una differenza che
t un significato Perché quasi lo mesmo
45 50 40 lo
mesmo è simmetrica è simmetrica St
razione è simmetrica sì e Pens una
razione asimet
simmet pode colocar oimo anterior pinho
antes Doimo No perch
Massimo Iso
FX Eh non
Go bloc
BL mais
BL
non
confianza
che
[Musica]
pun
SC
punto Us
una
nono sai perché forse perché un poco che
non
simol non
che mia casa che che
Int Tempor anteriore du lados
[Musica]
eh pazen a sta se incendo con meno
apertamento e sta con dor Mh allora me
fa un numero da
dor zero zero non St Zer erer Zer m non
te do V
temporale meglio che sta chi la linea d'
Vito eh
aqui zero zero Temp
poeri zero
zero Med
dis interior
Aqui
ha in pedig eh non è
ped Zero
Zer
feliss
superiore Io
sto
apertando Zer o Atlas che
staas
mandibola
stesso non maesso trasverso
cons
zero
per
aqui
aqui Ah sì Non fiscia perché non
important
pooi important Sì fiscia non St
perché
aprent falt costas
ah
da aqui S Guarda a pergunta
aar De no do ah ah viva minha
filha S
Sada Ah senta Por
favor Mauro Fez Uma pergunta minuto
minuto depis vamos colocar as
mos
vamos abert toda a articula Sa de Eu fa
come
fqu qu
Zer
Iso
aqui hum
aqui Tudo deixa tirar foto Vai T
filmando Tem Como tirar foto Agora Mas D
T pegando aqui na na Grava pronto T joia
pronto depois desse vou Fazer
a Ah Isso aqui de todo dia que é aqui
que quando voltar do Almo minusculo né
Mauro Fez Uma pergunta Fala Mauro
tranquilo V na pergunta